just so Beyonce knows I changed the
letters so don't come for me
hey I'm Hannah I'm fresh off the battle
with yamaneika saunders yeah make a
congratulation thank you oh my god it
wasn't like your grandmother's battle
we're just standing pictures of stay was
like prison you know I'm saying the only
thing is he didn't put his dick in my
ass that bitch will talk over you in a
minute that's why I will not give her no
dick you know I put my damn dick in his
ass you watch these white girl they come
in under undertow look at them wide as
nostrils on your face
this bitch literally got a sawed-off
nose hey everybody know I'm a prop Tommy
you know saying shout out to carrot top
you know I'm saying I see what you're
doing out there baby you don't say I'm
just trying to hit a fire does he not
see his nostrils
you got a gap and nostrils you ain't
nothing but open space so you can't find
not nowhere to park on Sunset Park it is
no oh yeah it was another fat joke
though yamaneika got a waterbed but the
bitch sleep in the deep end Alex quit
med school to pursue stand-up comedy
he's the only Asian to disappoint his
parents more than I did
Rob and I did drop out because the law
like you I can't handle periods
Alex Wang and Robyn Tran how are we
feeling
you know rose petal is fine for me cuz
like I read YouTube comments you know
for the way I look first comment always
at you you know what yeah and you
dressed in costume mask why I was like
hey it's gonna be TV let's have fun
shout out to Amazon Prime for getting in
here from China in time you know despite
the fact that you do not know what to
wear under a one-piece thing like that
did you not try it out with the lights
with the undergarment I did not I did
not try it on with the lights
do you either of you have a joke that
you didn't use that you wish you had
there was a joke that I used before it's
my favorite joke
Alex looks like he says yo Dawg a lot
like yo Dawg can I eat yo dog I'm just
really happy with how it went you know I
think it's like you want to make sure
you respect the person it's all out of
love there's so much love in roast
battle so yeah I don't like the idea
that you can't make fun of any group or
if it's like oh these are the jokes and
like they're all horrible jokes like on
Twitter you know that also takes Talent
which a lot of those people that don't
have yeah they don't have it
[Laughter]
[Applause]